melanin or melanin
you do need to recharge off your velvet
skin make them feel like
like 12 again as soon as i get the green
light i'm delving in
melanin on melanin your fellow need to
recharge off your velvet skin
make her feel like like 12 again as soon
as i get the green light i'm delving in
learn to balance it's real tricky like
the credible hulk turned back to bill
bixby
masturbating i'd rather wait then keep a
good enough good stuff for that trading
in
each and every day making cash was
saying can't eat can't sleep it's
exasperating
mad light burning off all they need is
one warm hug to keep
turning off i know you could use a boost
left the houthi back in the hood with
the screws loose
bust the coupe out the driveway stash
house scoop you up hit the highway and
mash out
matte black like melanin or melon and of
course the butter soft black leather
trim
setter rims little purr not a scratch on
it
spin it back to the garage and put a
latch on it
i need a handful of melon and feeling
like your lambs will build on this
tender skin
it might feel a light shock initially as
you connect up the flow
electricity through phenomenal melanin
and biopolymer
feeling like a glass of merlot i could
swallow her
eat it up like a snack well we could
live forever like henrietta lacked cells
melanin or melanin action where the heli
been soon as he felt the skin
holding hands feet in the sand grounded
staring in the pretty brown eyes
astounded
i suggest a solar power if you let me
pound it we could go for hours
and then again in the shower left leg
tremble and recharge the
[Music]
need melanin let that show
this is how you know
feelings
love that yo
[Music]
this is how you know
[Music]
feelings
loving god
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
get it
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
it's did
[Music]
follow the light the light is your guide
and i've invited you here to discuss
something
that's very important
[Music]
yep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
then
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
see
super
[Music]
super
[Music]
super
[Music]
super
[Music]
do
[Music]
super
[Music]
super
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
super
[Music]
super
super
super